Assume that this is the curve that describes
the dependence of position on time.
What would be the curve that describes the
dependence of velocity x dot on time--
the red one, the green one, the purple one--
and this is getting a little more complex.
Assume that this is again a curve that describes
the dependence of position on time.
What about the second derivative?
If you repeat that same process again--
the derivative of the derivative,
the rate of change of the rate of change--
that's nothing but acceleration.
Acceleration is the rate of change of velocity.
How quickly does velocity change?
So what would the acceleration be on the red curve--
the green curve or the purple curve.